[Musik]
ja der heilsbringer kommt aus monaco das
ist wohl die botschaft von schale claire
an ferrari nach seinem sieg beim großen
preis von italien am sonntag in monza
war der zweite binnen einer woche und es
war gleichzeitig die zweite schwere
niederlage für sebastian vettel eine
noch größere wegen eines fahrfehlers und
eines dann anschließenden desasters rang
13 nur keine punkte für vettel
und das bedeutet eben darauf hin dass
der machtwechsel bei ferrari zumindest
von außen betrachtet fast umgesetzt dass
tausende von ferraristi feierten lag
leer während vettel ja getrübt von dann
schlich müsste man fast sagen aber
dieses rennen hat noch eine weitere
symbolik zu bieten es geht glaube ich
auch darum dass le claire an den ganz
großen ansatz hat er möchte natürlich in
naher zukunft weltmeister auch werden
und dazu spielte das duell mit hamilton
eine rolle
insofern ist es vielleicht nicht ganz
verwunderlich dass die entscheidung der
strecken kommissare ja ich würde sagen
ein bisschen auch durch eine ferrari rot
gefärbte brille geführt wurden denn le
claire ist ein versprechen auf die
zukunft der formel 1 er ist jemand der
das establishment angreift der sich an
die grenzen der der regeln herantastet
und dabei eben am sonntag ein mann wie
hamilton hinter sich ließ man hat aber
die diskussion um diese fahrweise auch
dazu geführt dass viele im fahrerlager
ein bisschen den kopf schüttelten und
sich fragten was ist denn da eigentlich
am sonntag passiert ich meine wir haben
einen paradigmenwechsel gesehen wir
haben festgestellt dass formel 1 fahrer
jetzt freier fahren dürfen als das noch
vor ein paar monaten der fall war
fairerweise muss man sagen dass die
fahrer das selbst gefordert hatten das
war jedenfalls der hinweis des
rennleiters michael maze
nach der kritik an den entscheidungen
der strecken kommen ist aber was hatten
die getan
sie hatten die erste attacke von le
claire als hamilton auf guter
spur war erklärt zu überholen
hinausgedrängt in den notausgang
danach gab es eine so genannte schwarz
weiße flagge ausgegraben aus dem fundus
der bestrafungs rituale
sie ist nichts anderes als eine
verwarnung sie sagt aber frei übersetzt
das lügner unfair gefahren ist
trotzdem hat er beim nächsten mal als er
einen fahrfehler begangen und durch die
erste schikane schoss wieder vor der
nase von hamilton auftaucht und dieser
tatsächlich eine zweite chance hatte zu
überholen sich zu einem zickzack manöver
hinreißen das was ja eigentlich auch
verpönt ist aber da passierte nichts
insofern ist die kritik von
mercedes-teamchef toto wolff dass es
wohl keinen sinn habe auf eine
bestrafung in italien zu rechnet für den
italienischen für ein italienisches team
noch dazu eben für ferrari wohl nicht
ganz von der hand zu weisen was bedeutet
das aber letztendlich hamilton kündigte
an dass er seine fahrweise anpassen
werde
falls entwickle er der auffassung sei
dass dieses manöver auch im umgekehrten
rollen okay sei davon ist schwer
auszugehen
gleichzeitig wird auch sebastian vettel
nicht vergessen was am samstag beim
qualifying passiert ist als es trotz
einer absprache nicht zum
windschattenfahren von le claire
zugunsten von vettel gekommen ist vettel
hätte die chance gehabt auf die pole
position zu fahren
es wäre vielleicht ein ganz anderes
rennen für ihn geworden was bedeutet das
für die formel 1 ich gehe von einer
verhärtung aus im kleinen also im
ferrari aber auch in großen auf die
ganze sicht und wir werden in zukunft
rennen sehen die auf biegen und brechen
geführt werden das ist meines erachtens
vor dem hintergrund der unfälle die in
jüngster zeit in den ruppigen
nachwuchsklassen gegeben hat bedenklich
die neue freiheit begleitet aus meiner
sicht ein mulmiges gefühl so weit das
muss
[Musik]